[Music]
[Applause]
sean salisbury former nfl quarterback
and uh host of the sean salisbury show
in sports talk 790 in houston and the
former usc quarterback hi sean
how you doing i'm listening to you
talking about dan brown hi i'm sean
you're james patterson uh
here's my problem dan i went to i went
to heb grocery store the other day i
thought the same thing in the grocery
checkout guy says well i'd check out
groceries what kind of celebrity are you
so i go through that every day of my
damn life you just went through it once
good to be all with you man how are you
i'm good good good to talk to you i saw
i saw your uh your tweet where you were
a little fired up about your your alma
mater usc uh what makes you most upset
about this situation
i'm quite tired of our alma mater us as
former players
uh board of regents alumni fans and you
know dan i love my trojans and you're
familiar with our we've talked about it
for many years
is the arrogance and pride that we think
a 17-year-old kid
who plays madden has any idea that i
played or that we won a national
championship in 78 they don't care
hey man you got to do it the trojan way
yeah what's the trojan way going 8-3 and
and ended up in the in el paso and
you're playing in a game at utep and i'm
being a bit facetious but dan that it
bothers me because we got to get out of
that mode of
17 year old kids had about have about a
five year attention span they want to
know about name image and likeness they
want to make sure they can play on tv
every week national tv they want to make
sure they can play for a national title
they want to make sure that uh that the
nfl is waiting on them and that you
understand what you know where they're
coming from the kid at modern day think
about this dan the kid at modern day
knows more about the uniforms at oregon
and they're a good program than they do
about student body right so if you're
going to be the next coach you better
buy in so the arrogance of us see the
history and tradition of a program those
kids can get that when they get there
the history is for you and i to mull
over dan remember when i was in 1981 and
i was a recruited and can you say that
to a kid he goes
no no sean i didn't even know you did
that man remember and that's probably
the grocery checker kid let alone the
recruit so you've got to understand
nick say you've got to do the now and
what's happening what's going to happen
the next five years for them that's what
they want to know they could care less
about history and tradition that's just
that's the era we're in and that next
coach better understand that and he
better keep guys in 150 mile radius in
the state and in the southern california
area and at usc okay is this a marquee
job that you can go out and say hey
we want you
like we can pick and choose who we want
is it
a great program it it's a dan the name's
great and i don't want this to sound
conflicted uh conflictory to what i said
it's still people still know who usc is
the problem is we can't it's like going
in and misplaced when you're going
through an interview misplacing what
you're trying to sell about your program
i'm not trying to sell marcus ellen
heisman trophy when you walk into mckay
center you'll see that once we got you
on campus dan when i was there and
before me and after me with all those
great players and it wasn't one of them
like we you know we need dogs in the
program we got good players don't
misunderstand me but think about four of
the top quarterbacks in college football
they're all playing in the sc they're
playing somewhere else
and it's not a knock on slow but it's
just the yearly thing we used to be if
you came in to think about a dog in your
backyard and we need dogs in the program
but it used to be that in our backyard
if you wanted to take us out of southern
california
that you had to come in pick us up steal
us and take us and here's the recruiting
trip here's where you are here's why you
want to play here now we had us we just
opened the gate for you oh come on out
man go on and play for nick saban he can
waltz into your backyard when a guy at
modern day knows more about alabama's
program than he does the guys that are
within 30 miles or 50 miles of campus we
got a problem yes it's still got that it
is usc but we're no longer that guy dan
we're a guy it's like the guy the third
the backup tight end who's trying to be
that guy but he's not yet we're now used
to be that guy now we're just a guy in
in college football that we're a guy to
to oregon we're a guy to clemson we're a
guy to those programs and there's a
bunch of us florida state miami texas uh
nebraska but we're at the top of that so
we're still it's still usc but it isn't
usc okay
you gotta recruit hard all right
i'm gonna let you bring them in
okay i'm the i'm the a.d yeah
there's 50 guys we're going to hear and
i i don't need to repeat the james
franklin's and the match i'd love i'd
love to interview him let me give you a
few that i'd be really interested in
talking to and that i like i need
somebody i don't care if he's 65
or 36 i need energy to match the player
and understand landscapes change so
a sneaky name why not joe brady
young guy
everywhere he's been joe joe burrell
what he's gonna do with darnold and i
like him and he's done it quickly and it
needs a quick turnaround and he'll have
22 first-rounders a year so he's the
offensive coordinator with carol for
carolina and who was at the lsu and
borough had that big year yeah i'm just
giving you sneak i'm not giving you the
franklins or campbells i also am
intrigued with hugh freeze
liberty's doing some great things i like
how he's turned it around he's he's
coached in big time scc a little risky
though
dan you know what we guess what
sometimes that baggage it may be a
duffel bag now instead of a full three
three-piece suitcase okay i'm willing to
take a little bit of risk to get all the
reward usc needs i like eric the enemy
and here's why no southern california
continues to get denied in the nfl it
takes a lot to bring that guy you know
the nfl coach who's used to it now he's
got to go babysit in college but the
enemy you know southern california knows
recruits and also it's a guy with so
much energy i think eb's in his 50s dan
but when you when you're around him
there's an enthusiasm that he's 30. and
he also enthusiasm that he he
understands what these kids want and he
can take some of what andy's doing what
he wants i like that of course i like
jack del rio because there's a toughness
about him dan that's another thing we've
lacked we're getting our
our rear end taken to the woodshed
physically at the line of scrimmage and
that's not the way it's supposed to be
you've got to be able to do a lot of
concepts but nick saban when he needs to
can hand it off eight straight times and
wear you out so those are some names and
then you're gonna get your matt
campbell's your mario cristobals your
you know your james franklin's i get it
i'm i'm intrigued with brian dable in
buffalo and see what he can do but does
he even want to coach college football
so there are some names my guy jack del
rio would be great because he
understands the landscape and he's tough
and more importantly dan than just the
head coach please find me a friggin
staff you better have guys that want to
go spin friday night recruiting it can't
be
nick saban is a great recruiter and he
still does it but dan let's face facts
players recruit nick saban now right i
want to be there that's the way it used
to be with john robinson when i was
there i want to play for that guy but
now it's to the point you really got you
got to do some leg work you got to drive
to bakersfield and go get that guy you
got to show up at modern day at crenshaw
at verbum day all it's crispy and we're
not doing enough clay health the good
guy but the leadership's been lost you
have got to change it and it can't i
don't care if it's a sexy name i need a
guy who understands the player and can
recruit the player but also where the
mom and dad say ooh
he's going to make a million in name
image and likeness and we're going to
play for a national title we can't be
just the guy we got to be that guy or
we'll continue to be chasing teams like
oregon and other teams into pac-12 sean
salisbury former nfl quarterback and of
course host of the salisbury show sports
talk 790 in houston hey how about them
texans man
um
well dan probably a one seed in the nfl
playoffs because we don't overreact on
first week dan the one thing i did and
i'll say this out loud and scream to the
high evans i think that tyrod taylor was
perfect for what they had to have this
year
i think he's a more patient quarterback
than deshawn watson because he doesn't
have the hero syndrome have to make
every play but in the process desean
will make 50 more plays against great
teams i don't know how much chance they
got against cleveland
it may be a little bit of toledo versus
notre dame but if they can play like
toledo did we may have a shot but
they're going to have to do everything
perfect because i still think cleveland
after their performance is a
final four super bowl caliber and could
be in that position but the texans
better enjoy it and that's why i'm glass
half full enjoy it while you can because
you may not be jumping and hitting your
head on the ceiling many more times
during this season
great to catch up with you as always
thanks for bringing the passion i
appreciate it brother thanks for having
me on that sean salisbury
sports talk 790 in houston